okay you what is your grievance
i just want to know why you hate single
mothers so much
and what makes you think i hate single
mothers the way you talk about
everyone on your channel okay and what
have you heard what am i talking about
you just make single mothers sound like
complete scum
did you listen to the first 15 minutes
of the video
um i didn't no i didn't
oh my vegan i'm not going to repeat it
because i already covered it for the
rest of the audience i said in the chat
to go back and watch the beginning and
you'll understand it
there's no hate like what is the
grievance here exactly on
your other videos that you talk about
single moms you talk about them like
they're complete
trash and i'm not a single mother but i
think it's really offensive
okay so what's your position so why are
you actually offended by that if you're
not a single mother
i'm offended because my mom raised me as
a single mother
and i don't think you should be talking
trash about women who are working hard
with what they have
okay so what's the trash explaining the
trash part to me
some of the other things you say in
other videos you just make women sound
horrible
like men are so much better than women
women are just about [ __ ] you guys
can you be specific
i am being specific i want to know why
you have such a
anger and hatred in your heart towards
single mothers
there's no anger there's no hatred
that's not what he comes up with when
you watch your videos
john i have i have zero
anger or hatred or dislike for the
single mothers that i've dated
at all even the one that was like kind
of crazy and like stood me up and
didn't like that i was a good father i
find
i i have no problem with them at all but
they're not compatible for me to date
it's not a good option for me to spend
time with and put resources into
at all it doesn't have worked out and i
don't see
a positive situation for me personally
so let's ask this question for for
clarity so
what do you think this this this hate is
well i obviously think you've been hurt
by women
and i know you like to laugh about that
but it's not nice
what i was hurt by the government well
i'm
you guys can have your own opinion on
women but some women are trying their
hardest
you know some men aren't that great so
why are you so offended like i'm
i'm confused because if i say something
like well you're far better off dating a
woman without children than a woman with
children
why is that deemed as hatred by you it's
not hatred but some of the things you
guys say are not not you guys
um just richard okay some things that
you say
are very offensive towards women like
you obviously think that men are so much
better
what is it well i've watched a bunch of
your videos i'm not gonna i can't
remember everything off the top of my
head i just don't get why
you're offended by megan that's that's
what i'm asking you what is it that
you're offended by
why are you telling men not to date
women that have children
because women without children are
better that's not true
why is it not true what makes them
better than women that don't have
children
i mean how many how many single mothers
have you dated
i dated single dads before i got married
and um
you know what single dads aren't all
they're cracked up to be either
okay so a woman without kids doesn't
bring the level of complexity to a man's
life that a woman with kids brings
you understand that right
sort of but i just i just find it
offensive the way you talk about mothers
well you're only offended because it's
true people don't get offended if it's a
lie
i don't find it necessarily true i had a
deadbeat father
that you don't go around raw dogging
women and making children
i mean i'm sorry women need to have
accountability for who they choose to
have sex with
yes that's why is it always a guy's
fault i mean
i'm sorry but like unless she was raped
like women are in control
of who puts their penis in them and
they're
they have options of like 30 to 40
different types of birth control
that's i'm sorry it's like that's that's
ridiculous
okay like i'm sorry that's one of the
biggest problems with single mothers is
there's no accountability
what do you think you chose to have sex
with a
undesirable male that wasn't going to be
around
and got pregnant by them and you have 30
to 40 different options of birth control
yeah but how do you know and then we get
married someday like
i'm financially responsible for for your
children now also because of a mistake
you made
so did your mother take any ownership in
this mistake or was it all your dad's
fault
um no my mother takes responsibility as
well
okay so maybe i should ask you this
question why do you hate men
i don't hate men i have a son and i
don't hate men i love my husband i have
a son
well it seems like brother sent me
towards men and things that i say about
no i get resentment to people that are
talking [ __ ] about single mothers like
some
women work really hard to raise their
kids
it's uh youtube so try to limit the
swearing right
so my question to you is
do you think that single mothers are
just as good as women without children
or they're better i think i'm i'm a good
mother
and i'm a good woman and i have children
we're not talking about you because
you're married right you're a happily
married woman
yeah yeah you're looking to get divorced
like
your relationship no happily made okay
so you're happy married woman
with children but you're offended
because i say to guys hey look guys if
you're a 30 year old man
you're chasing excellence you don't have
any kids
you want to get on your purpose in life
stay away from single mothers and that's
offensive because
why exactly because there's women out
there that have kids that are single
mothers
that are good women okay but a woman
without children in tow is a better
choice for that guy
so why would he invite that level of
complexity into his life
but some men love children so what's
wrong with opening your heart to
someone's child
let me ask you this question so you're a
mother with a son so let's say that your
son
is 25 years old and he says hey mom i
got this great girl
she's got three kids two of them from
different fathers
i'm gonna bring them over for uh
thanksgiving
it depends on the woman oh now it
it depends on because some women aren't
completely crazy
and some women are really nice people
but let's say your son is dating
three women and two of them don't have
any children
they've got a great future ahead of them
you know they're
they're all 25 your son's 25 years old
uh
they've got a university degree blah
blah blah and he's got this one girl
who's got three kids in tow from two
different fathers who's also 25
who's got a train wreck of a life right
now she doesn't have things together and
she brings drama to the table
would you be telling your son you should
pick that woman with three kids or you
should go to sally over there who
doesn't have three kids
i would probably say the girl without
kids but i'm not saying that they're
better
it's not that funny nothing we're not
saying
taking all emotion out of it and we're
looking at like
you know factual things that are going
to happen to your life like
you're going to take on a more of a load
more responsibility it's harder work
to date a woman with kids there's some
men that
that have a married woman a woman with
children
okay well i'm not saying they're better
or not i'm just saying i don't think you
should talk so much crap about
mothers it's just advice i have friends
who have
who have married uh women who had
children and had children with them
awesome great i don't think any less of
them at all but like
if they were to call me and ask me for
advice i was like i don't know if this
is the best idea for you
just being honest not because she's not
a bad good person or whatever i don't
know anything about that i'm just saying
just financially whatever are you sure
i'm gonna check to make sure they're
absolutely sure
yeah yeah and guys are gonna be willing
to take on the extra bird and fine
that's up to them but guys need to
understand that they don't
have to you're not forced into that
situation and i think a lot of guys feel
like they're conditioned into like
you must you have to date single women
you don't you're allowed to have
whatever boundaries you want to and i
think that's the message we're trying to
get across
you can decide however you want to live
your life you can decide on whoever you
want to date and it's
okay yeah that's fair so megan are you a
stay-at-home mom or do you work
i must stay at home mom okay awesome so
that's so that's a nice job to have and
you got
one child two two children okay
and your husband works full-time yeah
what does he do for a living
he's a contractor okay so you've got a
guy that's facilitated a life where you
can be a stay-at-home mom and raise your
son
and be the parent that you wanted to be
but
you chose this man because he could
facilitate that you could have had the
choice of another guy let's say
that was also a contractor but had three
children in tow
from a prior mirror but you chose the
guy that had more disposable income
because you wanted that to facilitate
your stay-at-home mom lifestyle yeah
well i also helped me i have nothing
against
i have nothing against single women
there's some beautiful single women out
there
i'm just saying that you have to make
educated choices
as an adult if you want to get great
results out of life you have the result
that you have right now as a
stay-at-home mom raising your son
because your husband facilitates that
because of his job he didn't bring
extra drama to the table you chose that
that was a good choice
yeah you would probably encourage your
son to do the exact same thing when he's
an adult
it's got nothing to do with we don't
like or we like single
you know single mothers it's it's a
better choice for men
that are putting a dent in the universe
to not invite that layer of complexity
in their life
that's all it is okay yeah that's fair
enough
you get it i get it free page
awesome we're on the same page okay
thank you
people would be happy she's doing a
great job oh gosh
you